[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
hörte cupcakes gewünscht wir werden
rainbow dash cupcakes machen
und jetzt hat sie gesagt sie lernten
auch bisschen und mal bis hin und ich
darf hier die rainbow dash ausschneiden
denn das werden kate trotter und ich hab
dir einfach ausgebracht
da bist du hast du tust bis 100
gerechnet
boah was gibt den 50 50 100 wartet das
habe ich angefangen
wir holen die eine kleine schere um
gunnar d schneiden wir jetzt aus lassen
so einen kleinen weißen rand und dann
laminieren wir sie ein und schneiden sie
noch mal aus und zwar fragen jetzt
vielleicht manche wie solange sie nicht
ein und schneidest du dann aus dann ist
aber aus unserem papier amt und sich
nicht komplett eingeschweißt und
deswegen erst ausschneiden laminieren
und nochmal ausschneiden dann sind sie
100 prozent dicht vor allem auch weil
sehr später in die cupcakes reinkommen
und glaubt mir vertraut mir ich war
lange genug controllerin und habe lange
genug illuminiert
man hat diese linien sowie westimmo wenn
du jetzt schon darf ist die muffins
gebacken und können den backofen wird
dann schütze alle hände waschen zusammen
für mich passt das ist rainbird es ja
und da hat sich das ausgedacht und warum
ist rainbow dash so besonders
orientiert schmerzmittel ganz talentiert
hast du auch internet was ist es kann
ich die kunststücke fahrrad dafür dass
du es erst gelernt habe es beim fahrer
zu fahren sofort sei gut so als wenn dir
wie gesagt schon ausgeschnitten
da machen wir gleich weiter aber jetzt
werden wir erst mal den martinstag
machen und er nach findest du es okay
wir gelbe förmchen nehmen weil guck mal
ich hab mir gedacht weil doch die
strähne vorne von rainbow dash auch so
gelb und rot und orange ist wenn man das
so später rein macht sie doch bestimmt
cool aus ich weiß welch im fernsehen gut
fahren darf keine zu große ausgegeben
eigentlich gar keine auswahl setzt sie
einfach vor die entscheidung sagt hier
gelte förmchen
und entweder können wir grünen nehmen
klingt aber finca train potash nicht
drin und pink habe nur noch ganz wenige
die reiche nicht
also ich kann dir lila lila gesagt ja
also mit sila immer so sieht mitglieder
außer dunkel und so sieht's mit gelb aus
bisschen heller ok weißt du warst wir
machen halt halt
wir machen die hälfte li na und die
hefte blöcke ja wo ist einverstanden was
dort also das nennt sich ein kompromiss
wir sind einen kompromiss eingegangen
yahoo
denn jetzt machen wir etwas was mir
gefällt und was dir gefällt also jetzt
machen wir erstmal den machen teig dann
ebenfalls einen hellen tag mit streuseln
und wir zeigen erstmal die zutaten wird
die muffins nehmen wir 150 gramm zucker
und eine prise salz 200 gramm mehl von
halben teelöffel backpulver und ein
viertel teelöffel natron 100,2 ja etwas
bei mir exakt 150 bei sonnenblumenöl
kambodscha 45 ich kann schon mal die
mandeln mal das mache ich hier kurze
drinnen
[Applaus]
fukushima ist das stück ich lasse mich
fragst du dir mandeln hier rein schützen
und da gibst du jetzt einfach alle
trockenen zutaten rhein alles was
trocken ist sanskrit backpulver und nato
und die nassen staaten brauchen wir ja
jesus die trockenheit sowie das zu
berühren zutiefst er nicht macht die
drei okay ruft mama sag ich immer aber
hier das ist gleich beide reintun bei
der extrakt das recht
guck mal beim öl bittet um jetzt
eingefallen
und wenn das jetzt ein schritt ist auf
einmal rein schütten ja dann verklagt
hast du nicht unterschreiben
und jetzt erstmal alle lassen zutaten
verrühren man sagen hier streuten mal
ganz zum schluss ich glaub mir erhöhen
noch die buttermilch 100 jetzt
irgendeine trockenen zutaten zu deinen
flüssigen zutaten und dürfen vermischt
werden
von ganz allein
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir vanille machen
und wie schmeckt was kommt jetzt noch
ganz zum schluss die bunten konnten für
die streife zu gehen
in jedem supermarkt
jetzt nehmen wir den großen eis
portionierer muss man jetzt aber ganztag
aufpassen und jetzt nicht so arg
kleckern
jetzt kommt hier ein eis portionierer
von ja immer insel mafia so immer so
aber ich streite man
[Musik]
wenn ich dieses kurs kempchen möchten
da sitzt so viel rohes ei mehl was nicht
gepasst
das kriegt man da ganz auf schmerzen
ich mache ja sowieso gleich ob sexy
verzweifeln
hauptsache das kind kam pfeifen weil ich
mein die helaba macht ja aber immer
schmeckt wenn ich mit der musik also
kommt bis zum backofen im city 2 mit
ich mache gar ein okay
warte aber nicht mit der hand rein gehen
ja und das ist ganz ganz ganz heißer
ofen der schon vorgeheizt es gebe ich
dir am besten sofort ja
[Musik]
jetzt scheine eher rundlich so hier
damit sich die kinder nicht anschneiden
keine scharfen ecken die muffins sind
fertig und jetzt kommt die creme an die
reihe thema natürlich komplett abkühlen
lassen und jetzt gibt's eine frischkäse
quark sahne creme der kann es verstehen
mag ersetzt die lage noch durch quak
quak quak markt nimmt einfach frischkäse
stattdessen und sonne richtig einfache
creme und lecker zugleich die wir dann
eingefärbt und das ist dann die hälfte
des rainbow dash weiß also was nehmen
wir dafür brauchen
200 von frischkäse 200 gramm quark etwas
vanille extrakt 80 gramm puderzucker 400
gramm sahne sonderbar zum steif schlagen
und die lebensmittel farben gelb blau
und rot wir haben ja schon die muffins
gemacht
machen wir jetzt okay und da macht ja so
machen wir das jetzt kommt einfach der
frischkäse in die schüssel sage dann
quak quak jetzt nehmen wir hier viel
extrakt sein spezialgebiet
das reicht was reicht
sie erhöht meinen vanille extrakt
verbrauchen hier wurde zucker
jetzt wird ganz kurz erstmal wird
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das so langsam die sahne zugießen
und jetzt willst du immer genau
sonderliche dritten mal ins team muss
nicht immer so ein lüfter nehmen wie sie
ihn abschütteln und genau einen
teelöffel immerhin jetzt zählen wir mit
[Musik]
100 gramm aßen abstimmen
was
[Musik]
kiwi teelöffel raus und jetzt machen wir
jetzt
[Musik]
max
doch immer so ein ganzer finger frau und
schmeckt die creme mit nach kony
nachholen
also gut jetzt einmal die krähen kurz
auf kleine schälchen um sie dann ein zu
fernen bisschen und abschmecken und das
ok
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich erstmal ganz wenig nur an
damit war am anfang dass hier mit der
creme und der farbe könnte so ein
bisschen und dann römer den rest dreier
den fahrern unterheben
als wir machen blau gelb blau rot und du
willst auch noch lila weiß ich
hingefahren kann ich hier mal stellte
reinmachen mir du kannst geld für
erbrecht
[Musik]
restaurants aus blau und gelb grün
machen wie werde ich mich weil ich mir
schon mal was meint ihr cooles grün
machen
[Musik]
danach machen
na ja dann auch noch mal von lila
violett es einfach auf fragen die er
lade weißdorf ja das sieht gut aus und
jetzt gebe ich hier jemals dazu jetzt
schon unterheben und dafür auch am
besten immer mit lebensmittel verpassten
sie verändern die konsistenz nämlich
nicht so schön wir lebten noch mal mehr
warte mit ich helfe dir ganz groß und
unterheben
ich habe auch ein bisschen nach die
waren noch dunkle dran du musst dich
immer alles probieren hallo ich bin
platt machen die tasten
aber dann haben wir gleich keine creme
mehr für die kapuze
[Musik]
jetzt probieren wir mal was aus
tropischen restaurant wo muffins gemacht
oder auch mal mit verschieden farbigen
creme als topping auf cupcakes drauf
gespritzt jetzt machen wir mal so ich
nehme frische hier und ich möchte
einfach nicht dass sich die farben im
spritzbeutel vermischen sondern wirklich
erst kurz bevor sie praktisch die
muffins tropf gesprochen werden heute
kommen praktisch jede farbe für sich in
so einen spritzbeutel in der ich wohne
karte jetzt wird daraus eine rolle
gemacht siehst du das mache ich jetzt
ganz kurz mit allem zu
[Musik]
mit sturm haus juni wird sturm ok hab
ich mit cut machen
okay die x 1 die kleinkriege wurst
[Musik]
ich mache so wieder mit der karte
forderung lasse ich bin studie ist schon
toll kraut einfach nur kraut treffe ich
dann begann mit dem schenken mit der
scheibe macht
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir das alles wurst programm
das jetzt nehmen wir den bus ist bis
heute eine große stern thüle das ist so
eine fein gezackte vorneweg schneiden
spielereien trucks klein aber ich wollte
mich aus zu sehen zu groß machen lässt
raums genutzt hier im einschlagen
so legen wir die ganzen tag kann man es
machen jetzt alles gemeinsam
und hier schneide ich jetzt vorne
einfach freie spitze weg dann legen also
so jetzt haben wir unseren masterstudent
farben haben stehen jetzt aber kurz
meinen kühlschrank die creme ist jetzt
echt weich geworden denn wir haben viel
lange rum gerührt und ich stelle die
kosten lasse kalt wird also jetzt den
schritt von oben immer gut festhalten zu
halten
senkrecht halten und dann
jetzt sieht es doch aus wie als wäre es
von rainbow dash reife oder
[Musik]
so rainbow dash cupcakes den rainbow
dash
gleich
na wie schmeckt zuerst einmal kurz weg
nehmen
naja ich bin jetzt mit teig mit kuchen
und test bestanden
super also wenn ihr auch die rainbow
dash capex machen wollt dann schaut
gerne in meiner kostenlosen app vorbei
oder auch sehr ließ blog.de da stehen
noch mal alle zutaten ich dekoriert die
jetzt noch kurz fertigstellte kühl was
wir eigentlich machen wollten war dass
wir hier oben noch so kleine mini
marshmallows draufsetzen aber die hat
jemand aufgegessen
ich wollte kein fahrrad war ja nie was
also wird zumindest noch hla was ich
noch wissen wollte du hast doch mal
erzählt da gibts doch diese elemente der
harmonie
aber was bedeutet das denn und was sind
die elemente der harmonie was gibt's
dafür elemente da ist mir immer so ein
riegel stärksten fahrzeugs es gibt einem
haus tätig die politik hat gibt es nicht
irgendwie so hast du nicht mal gesagt so
freundlichkeit und ehrlichkeit oder
irgendwie sowas ja egal das kann man ja
nächstes mal nochmal ansprechen also bis
zur nächsten wahl
[Musik]